hi this is Brandon roar with how
decision trees work decision trees are
one of my favorite models they're simple
and they're powerful
in fact most high-performing Kaggle
entries are a combination of XG boost
which is a variant of decision tree and
some very clever feature engineering the
concept behind decision trees is
refreshingly straightforward imagine
creating a data set by recording the
time you left your house and noting
whether you arrived at work on time
looking at it you can see that for the
most part departure times before 8:15
result in punctuality and departure
times after 8:15 result in tardiness you
can summarize this pattern in a decision
tree the very first branching point is
the question did departure occur before
8:15 there are two branches yes and to
know for consistency we'll keep all of
our yeses on the left placing this
decision boundary divides the data up
into two groups and all of all though
there are some stragglers and exceptions
the overall pattern is captured by
placing this decision boundary at 8:15
if you depart before 8:15 you can be
reasonably sure of getting to work on
time if you depart after 8:15 you can be
reasonably sure of being late this is
the simplest decision tree possible a
single branch we can refine our estimate
of punctuality by subdividing both the
before 8:15 and the after 8:15 branches
if we add additional decision boundaries
at 8 o'clock and 8:30 then we can divide
up our arrival estimate more fully those
before 8 o'clock
are confidently on-time those between 8
and 8:15 are probably on time but not
guaranteed to be so similarly departure
times after 8:15 can be
right into those after 8:30 which are
almost certainly late and those before
8:30 which still have a small chance of
being on time this decision tree has two
levels decision trees can have as many
levels as you want
most often each decision point or node
has only two branches this example has a
single predictor variable and a
categorical target variable the
predictor variable is our departure time
and our target variable is our
punctuality whether or not we're late
because it has only two distinct values
its categorical decision trees with
categorical targets are also called
classification trees we can extend this
example to the case where there are two
predictor variables consider both the
departure time and the day of the week
we'll start counting at Monday equals
one so Saturday equals six and Sunday
equals seven inspecting the data we can
see that on Saturday and Sunday the
green filled Donuts representing being
late extend further to the left
this means that leaving at 8:10 is
probably sufficient to get you to work
on time on a weekday but probably not on
the weekend to represent this in a
decision tree we can start as we did
before by putting a decision boundary at
8:15 any departure times after 8:15 are
likely to be late departure times before
8:15 are inconsistent before we assumed
that they would be on time but now we
can see in the data that that's not
entirely true
to make our estimate better for the
weekends we can subdivide the before
8:15 departure times into weekday and
weekend now a weekday departure before
8:15 is confident lian time however
weekend departures before 8:15 are
mostly on time but not entirely we have
updated the decision tree with a No
that reflects this new decision boundary
now we can further refine our estimate
by de subdividing our weekend pre 8:15
departure times into before and after 8
o'clock before 8 o'clock almost all of
the arrivals are on time between 8:00
and 8:15 the majority of them are late
now we have our two-dimensional decision
tree neatly divided into four regions
two of them reflect on time arrivals and
two of them show late arrivals this is a
three level decision tree now note that
not all the branches need to extend down
to the same number of levels now we can
look at an example with a continuous
target variable rather than a
categorical one when a model is used to
make predictions about continuous
numerical variables it's also called a
regression tree so far we have looked at
1 & 2 dimensional classification trees
now we'll look at regression trees let's
consider the question of what time
someone wakes up as predicted by their
age the root of our regression tree is
an estimate for the entire data set in
this case if you had to make an estimate
without knowing someone's age a
reasonable guess would be 625 this is
the root of the decision tree a
reasonable first split is at age 25 on
average people younger than 25 wake up
at 7:05 and people older than 25 wake up
at 6 o'clock there's still a lot of
variation in the younger group so we can
split it again now the people younger
than 12 can be estimated to wake up at
7:45 and people between 12 and 25 can be
estimated to wake up at 6:40 the over 25
group can be meaningfully subdivided to
those between 25 and 40 wake up on
six-ten and those between 40 and 70 wake
up on average at 5:50 there's still a
lot of variation in the youngest group
so we can further subdivided by slicing
again on h8 we can refine the estimates
to more closely fit the data we can also
subdivide the 40 to 70 group on the
58-year line notice that we're getting
to where we only have one or two data
points per leaf of our tree this is a
dangerous condition and can lead to
overfitting which we'll talk more about
in a minute the resulting tree lets us
make a numerical estimate depending on
someone's age if I need to estimate the
wakeup time for a 36 year old for
instance I can start at the top of the
tree are they younger than 25 no go to
the right are they younger than 40 yes
go to the left the estimate then becomes
610 a.m. the structure of the decision
tree lets you sort people of any age
into their respective bin and make an
estimate about their wakeup time we can
also extend this regression tree example
to have two predictor variables if we
consider not only someone's age but the
month of the year as well then we can
find even richer patterns in North
America days are longer in summer months
and it gets lighter earlier in the
morning in this completely unrealistic
example children and teens are
unburdened by the rigorous schedules of
work in school and have their wakeup
time driven by when the Sun comes up on
the other hand adults fall into more
regular patterns fluctuating only
slightly with the seasons
again older people in this example tend
to wake up a little earlier we construct
this decision tree much the same as the
last one we start with the root a single
estimate that roughly fits the entire
data set 6:30 then we look for a good
place to put a decision boundary
we split the data on age 35 creating two
halves one for our under 35 population
with a wake-up time of 706 and one for
our over 35 population with a wake-up
time of 612 we repeat the process
subdividing our younger population on
whether it is before or after the middle
of September and whether it is before or
after the middle of March this isolates
the winter months from the summer months
winter months have a wake-up time of
7:30 for those under 35 and in the
summer months it's 656 then we can
revisit our over 35 population and split
them again on age 48 to get a more
accurate representation we can also go
back and subdivide our under 35 winter
wake-up times on age 18 someone under 18
in the winter will wake up at 7 54 as
opposed to 6 48 for those over 18 you
can start to see the emergence of the
tall corner Peaks as we make each
additional cut the shape of our decision
tree becomes a little bit closer to that
of the original data also you'll notice
in the upper right hand plot that the
decision boundaries begin to slice the
data set into regions of approximately
uniform color
the next cut continues this trend
focusing on dividing those younger than
35 in summer months to those older and
younger than 13 the shape of the model
becomes even more similar to that of the
data you can imagine continuing this
process until the model closely
represents the smooth trend underlying
the data each decision region would
become progressively smaller the
approximation to the underlying function
in the data would become progressively
better
the power of decision trees is not
without pitfalls an important one to
watch out for is overfitting returning
to our example of a single variable
regression tree age versus wake-up time
imagine that we continue to make cuts on
the age axis until there were only one
or two data points in each bucket when
we get to this point the decision tree
explains and fits the data very well it
fits too well not only does it capture
the underlying trend the smooth curve
that the data follows but it also
catches the noise the unmodeled
variation that's included in the
measured data if we were to take this
model and use it to make predictions
about new data the noise from the
training data would actually make our
predictions less accurate ideally we
want a decision tree to capture the
underlying trend but not to capture the
noise one way to safeguard against this
is to make sure that there are more than
a handful of data points in each leaf of
our decision tree that way if any noise
we'll be able to average itself out
another thing to watch out for is having
lots of variables we started with the
one-dimensional regression tree then
included month data to create a
two-dimensional regression tree decision
trees don't care how many dimensions we
have we could for instance also add
latitude the amount of exercise someone
gets on a given day their body mass
index and any other variables that we
think might be relevant to visualize
this we'll use a trick shared by
Geoffrey Hinton a renowned deep neural
network researcher he recommends to deal
with hyper planes in a 14 dimensional
space visualize a 3d space and say 14 to
yourself very loudly the challenge when
working with many variables then becomes
deciding which variable to branch on
when
growing our decision tree if there are
very many variables then this can
require a lot of computation also the
more variables we add the more data we
need to reliably choose between them
it's easy to get into a position where
the number of data points is comparable
to the number of variables when our
dataset is represented as a table this
manifests itself as the number of rows
being comparable to the number of
columns there are methods for dealing
with this such as randomly selecting a
variable to divide on at each branch but
it's something to keep an eye out for
and handle mindfully as long as you keep
your eyes open
for places where decision trees might
fail you're free to take advantage of
their strengths decision trees are
fantastic for when you want to make as
few assumptions about your data as
possible they're quite general they can
find nonlinear relationships between
your predictor variables and your target
variable as well as nonlinear
interactions between predictor variables
quadratic exponential cyclical and any
other relationships can all be revealed
as long as you have enough data to
support all the necessary cuts decision
trees can also find non smooth behaviors
sudden jumps and Peaks that other models
like linear regression or artificial
neural networks can hide sometimes
there's a good reason that decision
trees consistently outperform other
methods on data rich problems thanks for
tuning in and I hope this is helpful in
building your next project